foreign
s us up next in Amarillo Reba welcome to
the show
hey hey how are you
oh I'm a little nervous don't be scared
it's just us Reba we're not mean no oh
okay yeah Ken Coleman's not here Dr John
deloney's not here just a nice piece
definitely isn't here for sure super
nice this is a super nice show today
what's going on
Reba are you still there did she pass
out oh I'm sorry oh goodness gracious I
thought we lost you okay how can we help
today I've been waiting for a question
or something what the question comes
from you oh how can we help the question
um my husband is such a tight one that
we were supposed to go out with the
congregation last night and break the
Feast for Yom Kippur which is also
called the day of atonement yes um for
our beliefs and he when he he showered
and he
um got dressed but then when it was time
to go I told him how much the meal was
going to be 9.99 oh he couldn't spend
that much so my question is when is it
okay to start having a little fun or
spending a little bit but that's not
your question your question is how do I
get my husband to stop being a tight wad
you know you can spend 9.99
yeah
what's your what's your situation Reba
give us how much debt do you have
none none how much you have in savings
um none for me but for him I don't know
if he'd want me to tell you but he's got
a little Bank a little wad well if he
does then you do Reba you both are
married do you have separate bank
accounts no
yes
bank account why no because he's a tight
wad I'm not allowed to do anything all
right so now I'm out now we got it
read The Works to support herself as a
wife to douglas douglas
hold on and you guys this is a married
couple we're talking how long have y'all
been married Reba
um we've been together for about 10
years but only been married about three
and a half I believe it is okay
so what is happening here is that you
guys are not aligned you're not working
as a team and what happens is even these
small signs yeah of not having the same
bank account him not wanting to share
with you all of that like what ends up
happening is it ends up integrating into
other parts of your marriage and so it's
big red flags in general that you guys
could have a much more intimate a much
more Dynamic a much more deeper
relationship if you guys trusted each
other on all levels and it doesn't sound
like you do
he doesn't he had bad a bad ex and I'm
getting all the blame okay
um well until he deals with this baggage
this marriage is going to continue to
just be this weird mediocre roommate
situation
would you agree
yeah probably because that's what it
seems to be right now yeah can this old
dog learn new tricks Reba can we get him
to to go through Financial Peace
University with you to maybe get some
counseling together
I don't know okay you said you're
beginning to go to counseling and I
haven't been successful yet
okay
um what what spiritual affiliation are
you guys you said the day of atonement
all of that is
this is Messianic okay yep
um okay so I would get do you guys is it
a rabbi you have or a pastor Messianic
Jew I mean I'm familiar with that but
who Rabbi well we have people in the
congregation couples that take turns
doing a lesson
um we don't actually
uh have a rabbi up front Okay well I was
going to say just getting with someone I
mean you guys are have a spiritual
Community that's why I leans that way
first but even just good um yeah good
marriage you know counseling or therapy
which again he he's a adult so he's
going to decide uh if he wants to go or
not but I think one of the best things
that you can do Reba though is is have a
conversation with him
and tell him how you're feeling and why
you're feeling the ways you're feeling
and so just saying like we are I feel
like we're not enjoying life I feel like
things are so separate because they are
when it comes to our money and here's
what I want like here's the vision I
want for our marriage here's what I long
um to be as your wife here's what I want
as a husband here's what here's what
this looks like for me and why I want
that I want stability I want to be able
to do this life together and be a team
when we took vows you know what was it
three and a half years ago that that
this is what this is what I'm looking
for what I really want from you so tell
me what you're hearing and have this
conversation back and forth but I would
really have a heart to heart a serious
conversation with him that's more than
just the money and the more like and
more than just he won't spend 9.99 on a
meal uh this is going this is going
deeper does that make sense yes
okay yep
so and I want and I want this for you
guys
thank you I do too
but it's been a battle it's been a long
uphill battle I hear that well
especially when there's you know past
trauma and x's and this is how I grew up
experiencing money and now you're very
tight-fisted with it because you don't
want to get hurt again and so that's
where he seems to be coming from which
is understandable but we can't keep
living that way and you shouldn't pay
the price
for what had happened in the past either
do you know what I mean so
um yeah so I think you guys have some
some real heart-to-heart conversations
coming up soon
um and then that's what I would
encourage and then if there's any way
for him to love you as his wife and just
say as my husband will you please
um sit down and watch this first video
we're going to send you Financial Peace
University so hold on hang on the line
Reba and Austin will pick up
um and and you guys even just sit down
and watch the first one or two videos
together that that'll jump start you on
the financial side but if you can get
him uh to get a third party involved to
sit down and just have some some good
marriage marriage counseling marriage
therapy I think is one of the best
things ever because they they are able a
good therapist will be able to dig
underneath the surface of all of this
ask you good questions there's a lot of
self-reflection and understanding why
I'm doing things I'm doing and it's just
healthy
um so if you're able to do that I think
it's a real gift absolutely and if he's
unwilling to watch 45 minutes of a
lesson of Financial Peace University
then I think we need to take those more
drastic measures and go listen I cannot
continue like this being roommates I
signed up for this because I want to
become one yeah to have this level of
intimacy in relationship and money is
just a symptom of so much else going on
there every but don't say oh my God what
was his name douglas douglas don't say
Douglas you're a cheap Wad and I think
you need to watch this video right we
don't go after it with insults or with
sarcasm or anything truly with your
heart as his wife being as honest and as
vulnerable as you can be with him
um is a great place to start that
conversation because it can be easy to
point fingers and
it's one thing when you're you know 21
and getting married and this is all new
it's another when you're older and
you're in a different season of life and
you have all this baggage that you never
really dealt with and now you're just
hanging on to it all that's a much
harder thing to unpack and because
there's just decades and Decades of this
trauma that you haven't dealt with I'm
also going to throw in a copy of own
your past change your future along with
um Financial Peace University that's our
friend Dr John deloney's book and I
think a lot of this has to do with his
past and until we deal with that it's
going to be hard to affect our future
positively so hang on the line Reba and
we will make sure to gift you that book
John was just in the control room we
should have just had him jump in yeah I
know right on the following three but
here's what's fascinating always about
this about this show and this topic
George of money is is money problems are
never money problems it's never what
ends up happening right we think that oh
it's an issue here and he won't spend
the money but under a lot of money
problems is life stuff happening and
getting to the root system is so
important because money just magnifies
right who we are it amplifies who we are
and that's what it does and so you've
got to figure out at the root of who am
I and what is this amplifying and so
it's it's important work to do yeah we
can't just look at the external surface
issues there's always something bubbling
underneath and we got to deal with that
but it's so so worth it and we hear this
with debt-free screams on the stage we
try to get our money right and all of a
sudden our marriage improved yep and
there's a direct correlation there
because you have to deal with things
like communication and values and how we
operate when it comes to money so do
this stuff it's so worth it we're
cheering you on rebound